[Musique]
ça veut dire quoi une école publique
transformée en entreprise sociale c'est
rendre l'école autonome énergétiquement
yutosuffisance alimentaire afin de faire
des économies sur les factures
d'électricité de faire des économies sur
les factures de cantine scolaire et
commercialiser l'excédent énergétique et
l'excédent agricole
[Musique]
voilà weekend
depuis la Révolution
l'éducation n'a cessé de s'écrouler pas
à cause de la révolution mais parce que
l'État est devenu un peu démissionnaire
par exemple aujourd'hui c'est plus de
95% du budget qui est consacré à la
masse salariale de sorte qu'il ne reste
plus rien pour la formation pédagogique
des professeurs plus de matériel
pédagogiques plus d'entretien des écoles
[Musique]